bonjour et bienvenue dans les sept huit
week-ends l'émission consacrée aux
loisirs et aux idées de sorties tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission le
120 c'est ce week end dans les yvelines
des dizaines de manifestations sont
programmées à l'occasion de la fête les
amoureux pour faire le point nous
recevrons sur ce plateau sylvie lahoun à
la directrice divine tourisme au
chapitre sortie après trois mois de
fermeture le parc zoologique de thoiry
rouvre ses portes ce week end
comme chaque année de nouvelles espèces
seront visibles par le public les stars
de cette année 2007 seront les miennes
plus de détails dans cette émission
cinéma la responsable jeune public des
yeux d'elsa 200 siens l'école marine
pool vous donnera son coup de coeur de
la semaine
aujourd'hui ils consomment carroll avec
cate blanchette et plus en fin
d'émission un zoom sur les rendez vous à
ne pas manquer à ce week-end dans le
département
la saint valentin la fête des amoureux
approche à grands pas dans les yvelines
des dizaines de rendez vous romantiques
sont programmées pour ce 14 février
avant de recevoir sylvie lahoun à la
directrice divine tourisme coup de
projecteur sur l'abbaye des vaux de
cernay et le parc zoologique de thoiry
la structure propose des événements
insolites sur mesure a pour les couples
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images pour la saint valentin les
établissements des civils ont entamé une
opération à séduction dans l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay la direction joue la
carte historique de repas sont organisés
les 13 et 14 février dans l'ancienne
demeure cistercienne datant du xiième
siècle les couples pour ensuite passer
la nuit dans l'une des cinquante sept
chambres de l'établissement de recette
qui fonctionne depuis dix ans on a des
clients qui reviennent tous les ans pour
fêter la saint valentin mais si on a
même des clients qui viennent à deux
couples une table 2,4 pour fêter la
saint valentin sont originales mais ça
arrive donc c'est une soirée qui plaît
pas mal et sur laquelle on a de la
demande donc c'est pour ça qu'on y perd
tous les ans au niveau du menu
l'établissement a créé de nouveaux plats
pour ce rendez vous placera une saint
jacques avec une gambas oksibil hosni
corbas de nouvelle calédonie accompagné
d'une c6 n'a saint jambon de boeuf en
fait qui est séché fumée et une
mousseline de céleri un sabayon
citronnée c'est un plaque et pas trop
puissant goût et qui reste à faire les
produits naturels et seydou et ça plaît
à tout le monde à thoiry le pack joue
également les cupidons pour la cinquième
année consécutive un dîner romantique à
225 euros est organisé le dimanche ce
soir dans les salons historiques du
château 20 tables sont dressées pour
l'occasion un château des feux de
cheminée une ambiance tamisée et une
harpiste
quelque chose de très intime de bons
repas devant un bon feu de cheminée dans
un cadre historique je crois que ça
donne envie
cette année sept couples sur dix
fêteront la saint valentin en français
pour les célibataires ou les allergiques
à la fête de l'amour vous pouvez
toujours passer un bon dimanche au coin
du feu et pour un budget moins onéreux
après ce sujet à saint valentin en reste
dans ce thème avec sylvie léonard la
directrice divine tourisme bon jour où
je alors une petite réaction par rapport
au dojo de rodez boules qu'on vient de
voir l'écran une petite réaction c'est
des lieux propices à la saint valentin
en résumé dans les yvelines on a
énormément de lieux propices à la
saint-valentin effectivement on vient en
voir deux ans vient de voir deux qui
sont majeurs qui sont dans le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
pour l'abbaye des vaux de cernay et puis
dans le plus dans le centre yvelines
pour ce qui concerne touahri donc deux
lieux qui sont nos fers de lance
véritablement en dehors du château de
versailles
bien évidemment donc à conseiller
forcément ça va fort romantique un petit
peu insolite alors c'est vivre dans la
tradition et c'est vraiment ça peut
paraître insolite en région ile de
france
effectivement parce qu'on ne s'attend
pas à découvrir des lieux comme cela
dans une région qui est si proche de
paris et on a l'impression que les lieux
historiques et la saint-valentin
finalement vont de pair on voit que tous
les établissements historiques
par exemple je pense également au
pavillon henri iv à serge en branle et
propose des menus saint valentin
oui parce que en fait tous les lieux
historiques
ça rappelle tout de travers l'histoire
de france et puis l'histoire de france
c'est hutin tout un tas d'histoires
d'amour aussi donc forcément saint
valentin ça va avec et on en a beaucoup
dans les yvelines puisqu'on est vraiment
le berceau de l'histoire de france avant
de continuer avec vous si villa ou non
nous allons tout de suite écoutez les
réactions des yvelinois par rapport à
cette saint valentin à 2016 le resto la
semaine prochaine en bretagne vous savez
une servante ainsi tous les jours où 35
36 ans de mariage je vais certainement
faire un petit resto en amoureux
et offrir un cadeau pour mon copain mais
j'ai pas encore trouvé le cadeau de la
saint-valentin tous les jours on
n'attend pas la saint valentin pour
voilà on se baladera voilà un petit
resto a aussi pour pour marquer le coup
quoi les gens que je n'y pense pas
d'avancer tout de tout simple de
chocolat de tirer sans c'est tout on
l'entend dans les interviews les jeunes
et les moins jeunes vont plutôt aller au
restaurant pour cette saint valentin
c'est ce qui ressort également chez
devine tourisme vous avez ce sentiment
là alors en fait oui parce que la façon
dont on peut évaluer la demande nous
c'est grâce certainement à nos sites
internet
la rubrique qui est la plus demandée et
aussi sur nos newsletters que l'on
envoie à nos fidèles c'est celle de la
saint valentin en ce moment donc que ça
soit le week-end où que ce soit le dîner
au restaurant effectivement c'est
extrêmement demandés le francilien a
besoin d'un petit peu de se déconnecter
de son quotidien
et puis du coup cette cette fête de la
saint valentin le lui permet c'est du
coup il ya beaucoup de clics vous le
disiez sur votre site sur l'onglet
longtemps oui oui oui beaucoup plus
c'est à dire à peu près vous avez des
chiffres vous savez parfois plus pas du
tout j'ai pas les chiffres en tête mais
effectivement on en a parlé ce matin on
a fait le point sur ce qui fonctionne et
le mieux et c'est ça donc ça doit être
en ce moment peut-être un tiers de
déclic et quels sont les tables
justement recommandé pour pour les
yvelinois
alors il faut faire une sélection
forcément parce que ayant jamais j'en
aurai une multitude mais alors par
exemple on a un cabaret qui s'appelle le
cabaret du bout des prix qui est à
cerner la ville dans la vallée de
chevreuse c'est certainement quelque
chose d'un peu insolite parce que dans
la vallée de chevreuse on n'a pas idée
d'aller dans un cabaret qui est un peu
comme le comme le music hall
de la vallée de chevreuse donc il ya des
artistes de talent qui s'y produisent
des chanteurs des artistes visuels tout
ça c'est le 14
donc dimanche prochain le midi parce que
la servante ans a fait sur deux jours en
fait sa une sur le 13 et le 14 janvier
et dimanche donc certains ont choisi
2,14 midi d'autres c'est les 2 le 13 ou
le 14 enfin voilà ça dépend des
restaurants il ya d'autres choses on a
par exemple des restaurants au bord de
l'eau donc typiquement le l'endroit
romantique on en a un qui est à andrésy
qui s'appelle la goélette très
traditionnelle vous prenez un petit bac
et vous allez dans le restaurant
traditionnel donc ça donne vraiment une
idée un peu d'évasion que l'on appuie ce
qu'on prend le bac et on traverse on
traverse la scène et c'est vraiment un
rendez vous important pour l'économie du
département
cette saint valentin alors comme tous
les événements que ça soit pas que ça
soit la fin de l'année avec noël et le
réveillon du 1er janvier
tout ça donne lieu à des sorties et
effectivement nous nous sommes le lieu
de sortie des franciliens c'est vraiment
le département de sorties et de loisirs
des franciliens donc dès qu'il ya un
événement quel qu'il soit on en profite
en termes de développement économique
parce que ça augmente la consommation
dans nos cités dans nos restes en est là
c'est maintenant la place saq à niveau
au niveau des défaites du département c
c'est moins que le jour de l'an par
exemple certaines le ska le web peut
être on s'est peut-être un équivalent
leurs équivalents mais grosse tête
légèrement supérieur charbon n'a pas on
n'a pas vraiment fait notre top ten des
événements parce que d'abord ça dépend
des années
il ya des années où on a plus envie de
sortir il ya des effets des années un
peu plus compliqué en termes de
conjoncture c'est le cas cette année la
conjoncture et est difficile on a subi
ces fameuses événements de fin d'année
qui ont été compliquées pour
pour l'économie touristique donc voilà
maintenant on a certainement besoin de
ressortir et peut-être que la saint
valentin cette année sera encore plus
performante en termes de chiffre
d'affaires que les autres années
maintenant on a encore d'autres
restaurants parce que vous m'avez
demandé de recommander je recommande
donc et tout ça sur votre site
oui oui on a toute une liste de
restaurants après il ya ceux qui font
des menus saint valentin on a le fil
cause yaa fourqueux qui est un site qui
est un restaurant où le chef est à la
fois dans le guide gault et millau dans
le michelin donc ce n'est pas rien et
füle casillas est assez amusant parce
que c'est l'ancien meneur nom de
fourqueux donc on apprend l'histoire à
la fois et on découvre les mecs
extraordinaires que l'on peut consommer
et puis il y en a bien d'autres qui a
l'armoise à auch enel qui propose aussi
un menu saint valentin vous faites vos
courses à parly de la journée vous
faites votre shopping et puis le soir
vous allez à l'armoise qui est pas très
loin
et puis la table des blocs y est à
dampierre en face du château dont ça
s'est plutôt extraordinaire vous êtes
dans un environnement particulier donc
le château de dampierre se trouve juste
en face et la table des blocs y est
un étoilé michelin puisque christophe
blot va reprendre les recettes de grand
mère y apporter sa petite patte un peu
innovante pour proposer un menu spécial
saint valentin
donc c'est à ne pas ne pas manquer
puisqu'on parlait d'histoire et bien
cette phase du château de doncker donc
l'histoire à l'histoire est là en trente
secondes pouvez vous nous donner envie
de passer la saint-valentin dans les
yvelines
ah ben je crois que j'arrête pas de le
faire depuis le début de notre entretien
effectivement berceau de l'histoire de
france
les yvelines sont certainement très
adapté à passer eu pour passer une saint
valentin parce que il ya des sites
merveilleux qui font des événements
comme toi riz par exemple il ya des
restaurants étoilés michelin il ya des
restaurants très traditionnel typique au
bord de l'eau on a tout pour
correspondre à tous les goûts pour venir
dans les yvelines
donc il faut surtout pas hésiter à faire
venir son valentin ou valentine les
ennemis merci à vous de passer sur ce
plateau sylvie la ona je le rappelle la
sentence le dimanche 14 février
et si vous êtes à court d'idées
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
divine de tourisme l'adresse apparaît
justement à l'écran
coup de projecteur à présent sur une
exposition
la galerie alfred de vigny est de
voisins-le-bretonneux accueille jusqu'au
19 février prochain l'exposition douceur
obscur et brumeuse un travail d'auteur
en noir et blanc qui réunit trois
photographes claude chose denis luc loe
stéphane bré toa reportage à sephora à
manille apparu à la fin des années 1860
la photo couleur est aujourd'hui la plus
répandue dans le 8e art le monochrome
continue néanmoins de séduire les
photographes se trouve dans ce style une
manière d'aller à l'essentiel de
l'expression de leurs rares à l'image de
stéphane bretons qui parle noir et blanc
illustrent le ressenti d'un renoncement
au travers de son exposition the end en
noir et blanc pour une autre réalité que
je trouvais intéressante également une
sorte d'intemporalité le noir et blanc
fait partie de l'histoire de la
photographie et on est même une
singularité par rapport au cinéma par
exemple sa porte
un trait d'union entre je crois le
ressenti que peut partager tous les fils
des zooms sur terre à la fois dans
l'univers site alité mais également dans
l'intemporalité
le noir et blanc permet de mettre en
valeur les formes et l'éclairage du
sujet d'un cliché cet effet de contraste
est souvent associé aux jeux de
brouillard à la manière de brassaï ou
encore comme le propose claude chose qui
nous fait visiter les jardins du château
de versailles avec sa série manière de
montrer les jardins de versailles la
couleur n'aurait pas apporté grand chose
et je voulais que les gens se
concentrent sur le sujet plus que sur la
couleur la couleur souvent fait perdre
l'intérêt du sujet donc parce que il ya
de belles couleurs et j'ai souhaité que
le brouillard m'apporte ce côté couteau
ne qui amène aussi les regardant je
dirais à un peu à imaginer ce qu'il en
est la galerie d'alfred de vigny réunit
jusqu'au 19 février
le travail d'auteurs en noir et blanc de
stéphane bretons claude choses et denis
du clos avec sa série graphique in
memoriam représentant un système supposé
ordonnée qui a perdu le contact avec la
raison humaine témoignage du mémorial de
l'holocauste à berlin
après cette exposition zoom sur le
château de thoiry après trois mois de
fermeture le parc zoologique de thoiry
rouvre ses portes ce week-end comme
chaque année de nouvelles espèces seront
visibles par les visiteurs pour parler
de ces nouveautés nous recevons sur ce
plateau à le compte de la panouse
fondateur du parc zoologique de thoiry
bonjour alors bonjour alors quelles
seront les nouveautés pour la saison de
thoiry pourquoi qu'il y aura des yens
cette année
voilà donc ça rigole battoir hydro du
mois ça rigole justement parce que le
ricanement de la hyène quand elle s'y
met on entend jour et nuit
et c'est impressionnant il faut pas
oublier que la hyène n'est pas seulement
comme on dit un charognard
mais il des chasseuses redoutable alors
chez les hyènes moi personnellement je
trouve qu'il ya des comportements qui ne
place qu'à moitié
la patronne c'est les mâles chez leyens
et ils ont ils n'ont pas le pouvoir c
c'est une femelle yen qui est la grande
chef qui domine elles sont d'ailleurs
physiquement plus il faut pas se tromper
les hyènes 100 physiquement plus plus
haute et plus forte que les que les
hommes ça matriarcat alors c'est un
tunnel de verre toujours dans la dans la
durée de verre de 17 m oui même plus
qu'il ya 2 2 2 qui tunnel annexe pour
les enfants alors on peut très bien
avoir une photo du tunnel principal de
ses enfants des petits tunnels sous la
gueule des yens sur la griffe des hyènes
et vont il vaut mieux d'ailleurs être
protégé par le tunnel de verre parce que
les hyènes c'est très redoutable
rappelle une nuit j'avais passé on parle
on parle de shoot choisi dans le natal
on m'avait laissé dans
l'orge en me disant vous sortez pas
parce qu'il ya 50 yens qui vous veillez
pendant toute la nuit
c'est ce qui s'est passé non c'est un
aliment impressionnant une puissance de
mâchoire et puis en même temps
passionnant passion des animaux sociaux
et tout un matriarcat donc ça c'est une
visite pour les femmes cette partie si
chez les lions c'est pour les machos le
tunnel de verre des lions c'est pour les
machos et les tunnels de verdienne c'est
pour valoriser les femmes il y à leur
reer qui est très impressionnant
également qui devrait plaire au public
oui oui on les voit par en dessous le
wado dessus donc on peut vraiment aller
découvrir
et puis on voit les comportements et
vous pensez que c'est un animal qui peut
plaire au public ifa think a fasciné le
public s'est rué leyen sont très
présents d'abord il ya des expressions
populaire dans tous les moments de
continent après à propos de la hyène et
qui ne sont pas très flatteur pour la
hyène qui n'est un carnivore parmi
d'autres il n'y a pas de demi des
gentils et de méchants animaux c'est une
vision des hommes
les hyènes sont là pour réguler les
herbivores
elles sont à thoiry pour se reproduire
elle sauva soir ils vont se reproduire
puisque ça c'est le but des parcs et de
reproduire des animaux nous sommes
éleveurs de la faune sauvage et et
metteur en scène de parcs les deux
aspects sont tout aussi importants mais
le premier est d'ailleurs récemment le
sénat vient de voter une loi très
intéressant tous les parcs zoologiques
ont été inscrits dans la loi sur la
biodiversité avant nous étions au niveau
réglementaire nous étions l'émission
départ et zoologique et est reconnue au
niveau réglementaire en europe et en
france avec des obligations qui nous
coûte d'ailleurs très cher de pédagogie
d'élevage et odm et qui sont la raison
d'être des eaux et la s'est passé dans
la loi j'espère que ça passera à
l'assemblée
parce que c'est un cdh est reconnu par
la loi notamment des missions d'intérêt
général et est toujours quelque chose
d'encourageant et autour des hyènes il y
aura des animations qui seront proposées
alors chaque fois qu'elle nouvelles
espèces
il ya de nouvelles animations ce sont
les soigneurs qui parlent de leur métier
de leurs animaux tels qu'ils les
connaissent
c'est pas un cours
souvent que la jeune soigneur nous dit
rhodia ma fille à corbas oui mais j'ai
peur si un prof de sciences nat me pose
une question technique sur la génétique
de la iago se passionne des animaux bien
tu parles de ton métier c'est ce que le
public tout le monde et puis quand tu
sais pas tu peux tu dis vous demandez
aux profs de sciences nat pour garder à
sur internet
au contraire on est là pour éveiller
l'intérêt et qu'ensuite on apprenne mais
on n'est pas là pour passer ça faire la
grosse tête mais là pour s'amuser le
contact direct avec les animaux
on est immergé dans la boîte du par la
voiture on est immergé dans le tunnel de
verre on est immergé quand on passe sur
les passerelles c'est vraiment la
spécificité des parts du groupe touahri
immerger les visiteurs me et des animaux
et offrir des grands espaces aux animaux
autre nouveauté cette année ce sont les
dole
ils ont été hissés dans l'ancien enclos
des loups voilà alors en fait elles ce
sont les sur des cubes ces derniers qui
ont existant dans le monde
je prolonge bien la diff tongs et les qu
on était autrefois et/ou dole était
autrefois très présent et en asie en
europe y avait des meutes jusqu'à plus
de 100 individus alors ils ont la
différence des autres canidés sauvage
donc son antre le chacal et loup ils ont
une paire de dents en moins donc ils ont
le museau plus + d'écraser de ce fait
ils ne peuvent pas sauté à la gorge la
proie pour l'égorger comme les chiens ou
les loups alors ils chassent en meute et
puis c'est un peu cruel il arrache des
lambeaux de chair et la 3 minute qui
tuent leurs proies mais avec une
efficacité grande qui fait qu'en inde
autrefois et encore maintenant un lien
il reste dans un parc national en main
on craint autant les qu on que les
derbys dans un tigre sol beaucoup plus
fort
mais quand vous avez 10 20 30 qui vous
tombe dessus vous serez pas l'animal
très impressionnante un animal beau et
impressionnant et avec une vie sociale
impressionnante et justement le le dîner
dès qu'on a quand le sonneur les nourrit
et on voit le toutes les complexités
d'une hiérarchie quand vous avez dit cet
individu ensemble c'est passionnant à
voir c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que on a
su qu'à attendre le plus avec impatience
la réouverture qui nous téléphone c'est
ce qu'ont passeport pour touahri il y en
a beaucoup dans la région entre cinq et
dix mille dans la région parce qu'elles
viennent souvent certains parce que tous
les quinze jours
ça dépend s'ils habitent plus ou moins
loin pour voir touahri à différentes
saisons parce que ce qui est passionnant
aussi c'est tout le côté des fleurs il y
aura mois de mars d'établir une mer
bleue de jacinthes et puis après il ya
les magnolias les cerisiers les
rhododendrons les azalées là pour moi
pour l'instant il fait un peu froid mais
où l'hiver est fantastique pour regarder
les arbres pour se promener à thouaré en
forêt de rambouillet haute parce que
vous voyez l'histoire des armes
vous voyez qu'elle est l'arbre qui va
dominer l'autre et autour ouvrier de
squelettes à l'été les feuilles cash ou
si vous voulez connaître les l'histoire
de la forêt où ils en mai et le rapport
de chaque arbre l'un par rapport à
l'autre
les arbres sont des airs à thoiry on va
de nouveau remettre
isabelle il avait pris un petit coup de
froid donc on va remettre
habilité en rond et les arbres parle on
va les remettre en fonctionnement
parce que les arbres je parlais l'autre
fois les arbitres et à thoiry des corps
vivants ont un chêne vénérable qui fait
500 en assemblage qui est un arbre
remarquable
et puis les ennuis en rêvent les armes
monde immédiat aux produits tout on est
des êtres vivants comme les autres et
d'un seul coup j'ai découvert qu
effectivement les arbres sont nos frères
de sève et de sens parce que la sève et
le sens hôtels formule chimique très
compliqué avec une idée toute une série
de molécules les mêmes exactement sauf
une
l'air las fc le magnésium et le quai au
centre et le sens pour ceux qui les
rouges c'est l'hémoglobine donc la vie
végétale et animale ont pris le même
moyen de capter l'aide nous le sens nous
donne l'énergie dans les poumons par
l'oxygène de l'air pour doser les
poumons et la sève des arbres permet la
photosynthèse
c'est à dire le prendre l'énergie du
soleil pour créer l'oxygène dont nous
aurons besoin dans nos poumons
donc il ya une complémentarité
fantastique les armes sont vraiment nos
frères de sève et 200 et en plus ils
font la moitié d'un probable que l'autre
profite et l'asie pointe et donc des
arbres des animaux que demander de plus
à thoiry merci à vous d'être passé à sur
ce plateau ou souhaite vous souhaite
pour l'avertir qu'il y ait beaucoup de
monde dans les allées du parc de thoiry
la météo risque d'être capricieuse nous
souhaite quand même d'avoir beaucoup de
monde me théo sur toute une saison
rasées
après la pluie le beau temps comme on
dit bien sûr on passe maintenant notre
rubrique littérature direction à présent
le pavé du canal comme chaque semaine à
libre et vous fait découvrir de nouveaux
romans cette semaine zoom sur golem de
pierre assouline
un livre paru aux éditions à gallimard
et qui transporte les lecteurs dans
l'europe de l'est
écoutez aujourd'hui je vous présente
golem de pierre assouline qui est son
dernier roman
c'est un roman qui se trouve à mi chemin
entre le roman policier est le roman de
littérature donc l'intriguent la
principale intrigue se trouve dans
l'assassinât d'une femme qui se trouve
être la femme d'un maître d'échecs et
donc ça va être la fuite en avant de ce
maître d'échecs à travers la france puis
l'europe donc ce qui nous a plus
vraiment dans ce bouquin là c'est
surtout cette description tout ce voyage
dans l'europe de l'est
oui parcours pas mal de capital et il ya
une vraie être vraie belle écriture une
vraie profondeur dans le style et qui
vraiment nous promène et nous amène un
peu à découvrir tous et toutes ces
capitales de l'europe de l'est donc et
en plus de ça donc il ya cette fameuse
intrigue où il faut trouver le meurtrier
lui et surtout à la recherche du
meurtrier de sa femme et il cherche
désespérément à trouver à trouver la
faille
donc il y a cette vision là tu de
l'intrigué et qui va découler d'une
société secrète sur le transhumanisme
donc il ya aussi cette vision là du
roman qui a un aspect finalement très
peu en entend très peu parler de ça et
ça aussi c'est aussi l'intérêt la de
d'avoir une vision du transhumanisme et
qu'est ce que finalement la technologie
va amener
l'homme aujourd'hui un programmateur des
civils nous présente son cocker la
semaine cap sur le cinéma les yeux
d'elsa de saint-cyr-l'ecole le coup de
coeur des lieux d'alsace et carole de
todd haynes quand on va jouer la semaine
du 10 et du 17 février en version
française et en version originale sous
titrée c'est le film qui était à cannes
et qui a eu le prix d'interprétation
féminine pour rooney mara et que cate
blanchette aurait mérité également tant
elle est sublime dans ce film c'est
l'histoire d'une
d'une rencontre amoureuse donc entre
thérèse qui est une jeune employée dans
un magasin et carole king
une bourgeoise qui en plein en plein
divorce donc une rencontre a priori
qu'il ne devrait pas arriver et ce film
est vraiment somptueux tant au niveau de
la mise en scène que de l'image on est
dans les années 50
donc c'est un mélo mais vraiment mais un
mélo flamboyant
on n'est plus dans l'imagination
amoureuse que la passion elle même l on
est vraiment dans dans la tête de
l'héroïne qui est en pleine admiration
devant devant carole un personnage donc
jouer avec cate blanchette tout en
maîtrise presque en artificialité mais
vraiment très très très juste et l'image
l'image de ce film est sublime c'est
infini qui nous parle donc de
l'imagination amoureuse et aussi du
poids de l'intolérance sur sur nos vies
le gaucher
mimiques de mariage
audi on passe à présent autres sorties
de la semaine il ya du choix cette
semaine dans les salles obscures
moi je sors de là enchanté voilà j'ai
bien fini en tous les cas
et puis j'ai ma deuxième qui est
enceinte alors c'est vraiment
l'impression de vivre une histoire
non non c'est très très très sympa très
bien joué bon moi je trouve que c'est
quand même un peu lourd mais il ya
vraiment des passages où l'on rit le
scénario est pas super
il n'y a pas de y'a pas d'effets
surprise j'ai peint ses attendus quand
il était bien il a respecté toutes ses
promesses et franchement à revoir
c'était vraiment génial c'est cette idée
découle tout craché mais vraiment des
blagues à gogo c'était génial
c'est bien c'est bien il ya plein
d'humour moi je verrais ça change
avant de nous quitter trois rendez vous
à ne pas manquer ce week end dans le
département le championnat régional de
gymnastique est programmée ce week-end
au palais des sports d'el en cours les
meilleurs sportifs d'île de france
seront présents pour ce rendez vous les
favoris sur une nouvelle fois les
athlètes du club de gymnastique
d'elancourt maurepas avec marlène mike
était vice championne de france en 2015
et zélie leriche jeunes gymnastes de 10
ans qui a été déjà été championne de
france à une dernière s'ils voulaient
assister à l'événement la compétition
est gratuite
un autre événement à ne pas manquer pour
les amoureux du théâtre les liaisons
dangereuses une pièce de christine
letailleur est programmée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ce vendredi 12
février et samedi 13 février à 20h30 à
l'occasion de la saint valentin
le spectacle dure environ deux heures 45
si vous êtes intéressé a dépêché où il
reste quelques places
enfin la médiathèque le petit canal de
montillot bretonne organise un match up
ce samedi de 10h à 2,10 à 10 heures et
11 heures les participants pourront
manipuler des images pour créer un
montage vidéo l'atelier ouvert aux
enfants de plus de 11 ans devrait durer
une heure les vidéos seront ensuite
visibles tout l'après-midi dans le
médiatique
c'est la fin c'est la fin de cette cce
7,8 week-end merci de l'avoir suivi très
bon week-end sur tv fil 78